oh ja ja ja eher kräftig an
ja geht auf servus s kids und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
ihr erkennt an der kamera ist ein
besonderer tag die kameras ein bisschen
anders aus als sonst
dazu kann ich nur sagen dass hier diesen
stuhl werden heute nicht gebrauchen denn
die heutige challenge lautet minecraft
im stehen spielen so ich darf mich nicht
hinsetzen
ich sage euch so viel es ist sehr sehr
ungewohnt aber ungewohnt die neue
lifestyle und home serie von gespielt ja
klar aber wir haben in den ersten
minuten ganz gut gemacht habe ich
gefühlt warum es die schon genutzt was
wie kann er so schnell da oben sein
8 ist wahrscheinlich direkte hochgrat
aber auch hier den holen kann ich sag ja
du hast mich nicht gesehen
ja ja ja laut als person als auch dann
noch einer kommt alter was zur hölle
junge du bist so ein ekliger kitzbühel
hat den so easy haben können porno ohne
wird sicher denn richtig sie haben
können den typen die mit der gold
richtung meine ich da kommt der an- und
vergeigten wir einfach und rennt da auch
noch weg da kann ich nicht mal ihn töten
der reiter aber eigentlich ein sehr
guter rundenstart der gefällt mir
bewusst dieser typen nicht okay dann
greife ich eben nicht wenn du willst du
das nicht willst dass ich kreide gut da
verzichte ich an dieser stelle auftragen
von rund 100 dezibel haben gesehen nicht
so viel equipment effekt liebe mund
nicht zu voll nehmen da ist er doch
meist und erst dann hat einen test pet
wunderbar magnifico und er hatte sogar
noch eine hose die nehme ich mir sehr
gerne
die mache ich mir sehr gerne zu eigen so
gucken nächste gegner irgendwo anders
und er ist wie eine fluglinie die nur in
südamerika verlegt weil da sind glaube
ich die an kann das ganz sein
ja ich glaub ich hab jetzt nicht
prämiert und die anden sind in
südamerika das sollte eigentlich der
fall sein so ihr guckt man sieht ganz
gut aus hier vielleicht noch eine
bordelais leider nicht aber dafür hier
nochmal noch einen kompass in den
schatten portable zeit noch ganz nice
schon blutet vielleicht eher hinten in
dem zimmer noch das sieht eigentlich gut
aus weil wir es einen job kriegen können
wir uns einfach mal ein schaden entstand
auf dieses kleine steinchen kloppen das
wieder haben die wurde wahrscheinlich
nicht vermutet aber dass nur käse drin
ok dann gehen einfach raus suchen zur
nächsten gegner
compass tag gerade in die richtung nicht
dass wir jetzt überrascht werden
vorsichtig vorsichtig vorsichtig also
leute ich sagt diese challenge könnt ihr
auch gerne mal zu hause ausprobieren
die geht ist es ungewohnt und sie geht
ziemlich in den nacken
so viel kann ich auch noch sagen aber
ich hatte jetzt schon ein zwei versuche
über die change relativ schwierig ist
beziehungsweise am anfang hab ich mich
überhaupt nicht dran gewöhnen können
deswegen läuft es jetzt bisschen runder
in einer ersten runde habe ich nichts
hinbekommen
eine komplizierte sache ist auch dass
man sich so auf den tisch auf stützt so
und dann übertrieben sein trizeps
anspannt und post aber stützt sich auf
den tisch auf und dann 10 euro leggins
greift man zwangs drückt man zwangsweise
auf den tisch darauf so amann stützt
sich auf mit der hand so und natürlich
auch mit der hand in der man indem man
die maus hält das heißt man stützt sich
mit dieser maus hand auf und kann
deswegen die maus in manchen momenten
nicht bewegen in der man sie lieber
bewegen sollte zum beispiel man gerade
angegriffen wird das ist bisschen
ungünstig vielleicht zeigt sich dass
gleich nach plus natürlich m ist ganz
anderes gefühl
die weichen ganz ganz geile die achse
man eine feile verfehlen alle ich weiß
nicht ich weiß nicht einmal ob ihn als
heute lag wieder ein bisschen mein tier
und tnt und elend bei tnt black stars
gerne mal wieso es etwas was ist das
denn wie konnte ich warum so leute rund
um eur 2 es geht los net chase jamie
dimon den geak wickelt ich weiß alles
rausgequetscht mindest alles was zu
spannend ist aber okay ferner lag noch
neinstedt gehweg steht die kanzlerin der
fresse junge nein schon wieder die waffe
rausgequetscht gibt's doch nicht
alter schwede okay diese runde könnte
etwas knackig werden jetzt so ganz ohne
equipment immerhin tat mich niemand
direkt so wo ist mein level als ob ich
jetzt aus drei flaschen kann apple
bekommen habe sei nirgendwo
erfahrungspunkte oder den eisenstädter
lieber nicht nämlich lieber von abstand
von diesen typen hier wo ist der nächste
moment ihre games ist halt immer richtig
knackig saftig anja lais und wer hat
denn eisen schwert wo junge jetzt kommt
auch der anderen die meisten schwert und
bitte mach nicht zu den tage torino
jetzt bitte bitte bitte lass mich
einfach akzeptieren
ich fühl mal zu anderen gegnern so dass
ich mal umschauen ob da was für ihn
dabei ist
er ist ein kopf an kopf bis er ist im
cockpit und die andere kommen auf ihn zu
oder bitte klatschen wegklatschen weg
finde ich sehr nice von euch gerade
dreieinhalb herzen boxee box xbox live
helmut junge läuft diese rolle läuft auf
jeden fall oder von einer kopf ab
doch ausgewichen hätte mich locker
weggeholt who
okay sie durch sie durch die okay das
ist jetzt doch auch glaube ich es ist
für mich immer besser wenn man von den
leuten ab lässt als stunden lang
hinterher rennt den fc steinen an wie
eine inkontinente person den abm steht
hier vorne habe mich natürlich gesehen
meist mit 314 hit mit dem eisen schwert
ich sagt nach 540 dauern
nein ich lege ich lege aber hat eine
angel was sage ich leg ich hänge fest o
komm o komm o komm zu mir kommt mir
meint deutschen spitzen getrieben
nein nein muss was war das wieder
wegfliegt worte [ __ ] wie er da
weggeflogen ist alles klar ich boxe sie
einfach im wasser er fliegt gut 10
blöcke aus dem wasser raus
okay gut aber davon wollten jetzt nicht
stören lassen nicht für dich könnte die
angel wirklich nutzt nämlich weg zu
angeln zum beispiel hier wenn jetzt
übers wasser hinterher laufen macht aber
nicht finde ich ganz gut von ihm so wird
es keine ekeligen als bei marino
vielleicht ist es ein player sagt ok
entschieden ich jetzt keine angel ein
da ist er mir einen steilpass nicht
viele leben ganz ehrlich du hast nicht
viele leben ich habe vor live das
vielleicht 556 maximal sollte ich mir
holen können vor allem auf die bessere
waffe haben
ok ja na ja da hätte ich ihn haben kann
mich dann hängen geblieben wäre jetzt
kommt ihm hinter mir einer okay manchmal
kurz den abgang euch mal kurz die biege
schon eine kartoffel auf 1 decken würde
man lieber eine menge essen ist dass man
sprachlos achtung scheiß ok ok einfach
mal fünf top job reingefressen und dann
ist der match okay also wer gegen wen
wir haben auf jeden fall schon mal ins
netz geschafft in der challenge hier so
erging wegen meine freunde ich gegen
dich du ging mich eher gegen sich
ok meist warum auf mich versteht gar
nicht die kempener das halt immer so
boxee box euch ja das ist gerade richtig
schwierig ich kann überhaupt nicht
nachdenken
jetzt habt ihr habe ich glaube ich
nein nein es sieht mich weg alter double
kills vielen andern nein er gewinnt auch
noch gewinnt auch noch dreimal
abgestaubt die aber okay so ist es in
zweifel ganz akzeptieren das was von mir
mit der heutigen folge probiert diese
challenge unbedingt mal zu hause aus die
sehr knackig lesen zum nächsten video
wieder haut rein macht gut und